sur les amendements qui rentrent dans le
texte c'est tout à fait intéressant sauf
que jusqu'à présent nous n'avons vu que
des amendements de suppression alors une
fois qu'on s'est exprimé sur la
suppression il y en a des dizaines et
des dizaines et des dizaines qui sont
tout à fait similaires c'est la raison
pour laquelle le texte effectivement on
n'avance pas c'est assez assez
surprenant je dirais comme comme
technique
parlementaire puisque à la fois on nous
demande des explications sur la prise en
compte de la pénibilité comment on pense
accélérer par exemple les les la
convergence des régimes spéciaux tout
cela sont c'est dans des articles plus
loin donc c'est impatience
se traduit et ces contradictoires par
nombre d'affrontements de suppression de
l'article donc tout ça quoi
[Musique]